just one look
and she knows exactly which elephant is
which
she now has eighty of them each one has
suffered
lek chai alert knows all their stories
see the ear the other
damage from the hook until just a few
years ago
this elephant worked in a nearby riding
camp as the conservationist
explains he had to carry tourists around
every day
if he didn't obey his trainer would
pierce his thick skin
with a bull hook the thai activist has
been working to protect elephants for 25
years
with her foundation she aims to improve
the lives of the pachyderms
donations enable her to buy up animals
who've suffered especially harsh
treatment most of the elephants have
spent decades being ridden
or in showbiz but in chile's elephant
nature park
they no longer have to work or be in
chains
paying guests are allowed to watch the
elephants but nothing more
for our project people come and visit
they don't disturb elephant
they just wash and we use the money to
come and we can rescue
more and more again and again
like child alert has exposed animal
abuse using a hidden camera
for centuries wild elephants have been
subjected to prolonged violent taming
methods
now there are laws in thailand that
prohibit animal cruelty
but chai lurks says this has done little
to change the taming practice
known as elephant crushing they thai
every not now is the time for them to
use the hook and
they start looking at the blood bleeding
everywhere
the babies are completely you can see
the blood
when i work under copper i have to
i have to tell them pretend that i don't
i don't care
or i don't get that i don't get that
footage
but after i come home all the time i cry
i cry with a lot of disappoint about
human
i angry i angry with with the people
that is
be a part of that today
lek cheilert and her team are once again
on a rescue mission
this time the conservationists will
collect seven elephants from this riding
camp southwest of bangkok
and bring them to the reserve near
chiang mai
the camp owners themselves contacted
shiloh's foundation
and asked for help as hardly any
tourists are coming to ride the
elephants
due to the coronavirus pandemic
an adult elephant is usually worth about
2 million baht
or more than 50 000 but due to the
pandemic
the animals have become more of a burden
for their owners
it costs them nearly a thousand euros a
month for food and care
thanapot kayer is happy to at least get
1 million baht per elephant from chile's
foundation
our situation has been dire since the
start of the pandemic
we had to close the camp for months
but regardless of whether we're open or
closed we still have to take care of the
elephants
and we need to feed them every day we
were allowed to reopen on july 1st
but there are simply no visitors
the camp owner and his elephant tamers
don't want us to look too closely as the
animals are loaded onto the trucks
they say that for safety reasons we must
keep our distance
elephants they are not really easy to go
on the truck
because when they put in the truck is
mean their life will be chained again
they experience with many times move
from one place to other places
and they might be abused from one place
to the others
so now they think they will take them
somewhere which is they're not quite
sure
before setting off the elephants must be
fixed into place on the platforms
each animal gets its own frame made of
bamboo stalks
the elephants and the rescuers have a
journey of about 800 kilometers ahead of
them
the team has never transported so many
animals at once over such a long
distance
the convoy sets off in the early
afternoon
after less than half an hour the
vehicles have to make a stop
one of the elephants went into a rampage
on the truck bed and destroyed the
restraining bars holding it in place
now they have a major repair job on
their hands
many of them are nervous this is all the
time when we transport
they will start to damage and they
broken
the frame and throw the frame to the
road
and if we if we keep carrying on they
will take over the truck
after about an hour the problem is fixed
and the adventure can continue
the elephants now seem somewhat more
relaxed
the rescuers knew just what to do to
calm them down
most important they love to eat so
as long as they feel here they're not
they
they're not hungry and no one hit them
no one
beaten them i think the journey okay
the rest of the journey does indeed go
smoothly
the cool dusk is refreshing for both the
elephants and their rescuers
the next morning after a nearly 20-hour
drive the convoy reaches its destination
the elephant nature park north of chiang
mai the team is exhausted
black chillard has hardly slept but
nothing can dampen her mood
all of them happy because the journey is
quite stressed
elephant angry so now they are right
home
i feel relieved
once the restraining bars have been
removed it's time for the elephants to
take their first cautious steps
into a new life
the newcomers will have to be isolated
from the rest of the herd for two weeks
in order to prevent the possible spread
of disease
the rescuers freed the animals from all
their ropes and chains
[Music]
has provided a new home for well over
100 elephants
a home where they are no longer forced
to put on a show
where they can simply be elephants
you